Speaker 1: Let's see who else we want
to speak to. Why don't we go to? Oh,
I don't know. Maybe maybe we go to Trey
from Nashville. Trey, you're on the air.
Speaker 3: Hey, I wanted to ask you and
I'm not trying to drag you into this really
ugly fight that we see going on on the
left right now, but I'm just not quite
understanding this whole dispute over the Syria
chemical weapons attack that's going on with
the Young Turks and montane of them.
Speaker 1: I have no idea. I'm the
wrong guy to ask. I have absolutely no idea.
Speaker 3: I think I think that the general
thing is they're fighting over whether
the twenty eighteen chemical attacks
like that of allegedly Assad did against the
people in Syria, whether it actually happened.
Do you do you remember anything about that, that
attack and the reporting that went to a window
that Trump responded by doing airstrikes on Syria?
Speaker 1: Yet my belief is that it happened,
but I have I am the last person to weigh and I did
a segment earlier this week about the drama that's
happening on the left. And I did talk about the
twit Jimmy Dawg stuff a little bit, but I couldn't
tell you. I don't know. I have no idea who who
is it that the Young Turks is fighting with
Speaker 3: this guy, Aaron Mattey?
He's a he's a reporter. He's done a
lot of reporting in in Syria.
Speaker 1: OK, yeah. I have
no idea what's going on with them. I'm
sorry. I'm just not keeping up with it.
Speaker 3: OK, one really different side question
real quick. I just had a theory that I want to get
your take on. I'm going to go ahead and say
that in twenty twenty for the GOP, they're
going to want to try to take some kind of identity
politics appeal. And on their ticket they'll have
either a person of color or a woman on the ticket
so they can continue to appeal to the changing
demographics. Do you think that's possible?
Speaker 1: Yes, yes, very much so. Yeah.
The the right loves to attack identity
politics and then play it. And so, yeah,
I would not be at all surprised if that happened.
Speaker 3: Yeah. I'm just going to say so
this is my way to early prediction. So if
that happens is twenty point four we'll
see. But my guess is Tim Scott is going to
be the VP nominee in twenty twenty four.
Speaker 1: OK, all right. But let's, let's check
in in a few years, try and see if you're right. I
think that could be. Yeah. All right, thank you,
man, you have a good night. All right. You too,
today from Nashville. Great to hear from you.
Let's take a quick break. If you are holding to
talk to me, don't go anywhere, because we're
going right back to the phones after this.